a new Pentagon report describes what
happened during an ambush in the air
that killed four American soldiers and
injured two others
the report says multiple failures
including a lack of proper training led
to the four men's deaths the classified
version of the full report has yet to be
released
David Martin is at the Pentagon with new
information on that October firefight
David good morning good morning the
investigation found that a series of
failures by people and organizations
left that Patrol unable to deal with an
ambush they never saw coming
they were outnumbered three to one by a
well-trained and well-armed enemy if you
get to a position on in an operation
where you're under enemy contact you
need to be able to operate like
clockwork without having to speak
because you know the drills and in this
particular case the team did not conduct
those basic soldier level skills general
thomas waldhauser commander of US troops
in africa said the team of eleven
americans had not trained together
enough then they set out to capture a
terrorist a mission for which they did
not have proper approval but lead
investigator Major General Roger
Cloutier said the mistakes should not
obscure one other fact there were
numerous acts of extraordinary bravery
that occurred on that day the military's
digital recreation shows that when the
ambush hit the troops returned fire but
soon realized they were outgunned and
outnumbered and tried to drive out of
the kill zone one vehicle was left
behind sergeant Brian Black was the
first to fall sergeants Jeremiah Johnson
and Dustin Wright stayed with him until
overwhelming enemy fire forced them to
run
sergeant Jeremiah Johnson was shot and
rendered immobile sergeant Wright then
stopped to return to his teammates
position continuing to engage the enemy
until both were fatally wounded the rest
moved to a second position were again
overwhelmed and had to retreat unable to
make it to his vehicle sergeant Lee
David Johnson made a nearly eleven
hundred yard dash for Life which ended
at this thorn tree he continued to fight
despite early reports he had been
captured
Sarla David Johnson first of all died
act
engaging the enemy he was never captured
alive his hands were never bound 800
Americans remained in Niger but they
have now been given armoured vehicles in
which to patrol and told to scale back
their operations in order to reduce the
chances of coming in contact with the
enemy
John David thanks so much so now we know
what happened with the question why
there are those multiple failures and
John here that the family has to here
lack of proper training and a series of
failures led to the death of your loved
one that you get to see how it played
out it's got to be very painful
absolutely